vous vous moquez de moi 3 veut
particulièrement simple et en théorie
sans aucun risque j'ai été emprisonné
par salomon justement parce que j'ai
crié haut et fort ce que mon coeur
désiré je ne pourrais gagner ma
libération qu en exauçant vos souhaits
j'apprécie c'est très poétique mais le
fait est qu en ce qui concerne ma vie je
ne peux vraiment pas trouvé un seul voeu
intéressant alors comment formuler trou
y at il de la vie en vous êtes-vous
divorce savez vous que dans certaines
cultures l'absence de désir signifient
elles enchantent vous êtes pieux et
idiot mais si je suis satisfaite
pourquoi tant tel destin et vous cette
loge ne me provoquait pas il n'existe
aucun humain aucun os aucun jean qui ne
voudraient avoir la chance de satisfaire
ses plus grand désir je me retrouverai
avec la seule qui prétendent en avoir
aucun invité à bini vous êtes une
menteuse vous savez qu'elle veut je
devrais faire savoir
[Musique]